at the Isabella Stewart Gardner Museum
in Boston a thirty year old mystery
still brings pain and questions who
bluffed their way into the museum tied
up the guards and made off with 13 rare
paintings drawings and objects where are
the works now two of the most important
works that were stolen the concert by
Vermeer just one of 36 of his works in
existence and Christ in the storm on the
Sea of Galilee by Rembrandt his only
painting featuring a seascape seen
reports that the stolen items are worth
500 million dollars or more and
pragmatically that's a fair estimate
however I like to point out that the
pieces that were stolen from the Gardner
really are the true definition of
priceless nough solved they can never be
replaced a few years ago the FBI thought
this surveillance video could solve the
case it shows an unidentified man
walking through the museum after hours
just one night before the heist but that
and other clues just weren't enough to
help investigators another problem it
turns out both suspected robbers died a
year after the theft the message to the
public if you know something it's okay
to come forward we acknowledge the fact
that any or all of these pieces could be
in the hands of individuals who had
nothing to do with the original theft or
may not even know that they're stolen 30
years on the museum's ten million dollar
reward sits unclaimed while curators and
law enforcement hope these works one day
we'll return to the Gardner's walls
Rosalind Jordan al-jazeera Washington